j'ai jamais vu ça de ma vie
bonsoir tout le monde sur Tik Tok je
suis dans mon salon et je continue de
vous découvrir et je découvre que sur
TiK ToK on aime les défis et on aime
apprendre des choses et moi en anatomie
une des choses qui m'avait fascinée
quand j'ai étudié l'anatomie c'est que
nos squelettes hommes et femmes ont des
petites subtilités ce qui permet aux
femmes de faire ça et de déplier les
bras sans décoller les coudes mais pas
aux hommes en tout cas très peu d'hommes
testés et dites-moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Marseille bébé
regardez pareil s'il vous plaît là là
sens sens sens
s'offrir interdit vas-y je me tarif
c'est pas grave allez
voilà je suis bloqué c'est quoi le
délire là
on est déjà à 60 ans
[Musique]
ah tu étais malade toi
ça fait beaucoup d'impacts c'est à
manger ce matin il y a moyen que tu
fasses caca